I like your new digs you like this mmm
no laughter that I have to tell you the
last time I was on or maybe was the last
time I came around was but I remember I
was feeling very insecure about when you
were on this show that I was on this
show yeah I was feeling kind of insecure
about what I said or a story I told her
something this was your other format
yeah the other format that's all the
same yeah and I remember coming off
stage and say hey Andy and I was feeling
really insecure and I was a candy I
don't think that was very funny
and he goes Tony it doesn't matter and I
think you I think you even gave the
example of like it's like a paper boat
you put a paper boat in the ocean and it
just floats away that is very Andy that
is very well say it was very comforting
yeah there was just something kind of
comforting like you give power to stuff
that doesn't matter
well that's but back you know whatever
it's almost like 25 26 years ago when we
were starting out and I was so intense
about this show has to work and
sometimes I have a show that just I felt
terrible about I'm gonna turn to Andy
after the show and you'd be like what
are you gonna do like make a better one
that's what I know the thing I used to
say to him all the time is ah too bad we
don't get to make another one tomorrow
yeah if we did yeah yeah I like how you
explained it at the end